it's like that's a dick move right there
yeah yeah
like i hate my tongue right now
if i could pull it out i would
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today i'm joined by charlize theron
she's an academy award-winning actress
you know from iconic roles in films like
monster atomic blonde bad max fury road
and many more you can catch her in her
latest movie gringo sets it theaters
march 9th charlize welcome to the show
thank you for having me and then i know
that your son jax has nicknamed you mama
spicy should i read anything into that
before we dive into the hot sauce soup
here yeah i am mama spicy that's one of
my nicknames but i don't think it's the
connection to it doesn't spicy no i
think it's more
you know mom's pointing her finger and
being sassy how are you with hot food i
don't know how to answer that question
being on your show because i just feel
like this will be the ultimate test but
i enjoy spicy food i definitely love
spice
[Music]
um
[Music]
that's delicious
i like that
i might take that so i recently learned
danish from a scandinavian pepper eating
legend named chili klaus so since it was
such a success i'm hoping i can get a
two-minute lesson in afrikaans from you
on wing one can you give me a south
african phrase that i can use in my
everyday life when i was a kid i was the
the way they teach you to put your hand
in front of your mouth when you yawn
is through this little song and it's
like
yo hunt for a month
and that's one of my favorites so it's
not really a saying but it's just saying
like don't yawn with your mouth open
cover it can you give me a swear word or
some slang that i should know how nasty
do you want me to get get nasty really
mm-hmm
what does that mean it's like your
mother's private bits okay okay but not
that nice
i might say this later on we'll see
where it goes
[Music]
really nice too i like it first one more
sorry
did i hurt anybody's feelings no just
keep it real just keep it real out here
so it wouldn't be a first we feast
production unless we got really into the
weeds about your food proclivities so
with that in mind i want to cite a
vanity fair profile from 2011 where your
friend producer beth cono said and i
quote the woman can cook a 10 course
meal for 25 people i'm like are you mrs
doubtfire the charlize theron dinner
party what am i eating what am i
drinking what's going to get me kicked
out i need to know everything both just
a lot it's very south african too the
idea of socializing around food and
drink and that's kind of how i was
raised and once i kind of settled here
and had a home and i had a good group of
friends that that to me was like the
best friday or saturday night that i
could imagine and i do enjoy cooking but
i think it's more just the social aspect
of everybody in the kitchen and opening
a couple of bottles of wine what is the
difference between a bryan south africa
and a backyard cookout that you'd have
in la there's some staples that you have
to have for a bry
um we do these incredible things called
toasties where you just make like a
toasted sandwich on the grill with
tomato onion and cheese and you burn it
almost black on the outside and it gets
like super crunchy and the melted cheese
and the onion kind of pulls out and it's
like so delicious that we
then let it sog overnight in the tomato
juice and the next morning we eat it for
breakfast and it's so delicious yes
really delicious
[Music]
that's really yummy
go to this one
so far we're three for three okay
all right yeah
so you have such an extensive acting
resume i could probably talk to you all
day about your projects and still not
give the people everything they want to
know but i'll try on the green sauce to
hit some career highlights what was the
bigger accomplishment being named one of
time's 100 most influential people or
being an honorary green flag waiver at
the daytona 500.
and they're all pretty special
at daytona everybody was like how do you
feel about this and i was like i just
hope you guys didn't make a mistake and
there's a part of my personality that's
always like is that really did that
really happen and
and then the south african to me that's
like well i'm just gonna keep going with
this if nobody knows i'm not supposed to
be here then i'm just gonna keep going
with this time is probably like god we
made such a mistake was doing that but
suck it you did it
now you gotta stick with it and now i'm
gonna own it
how if at all do the months of fight
training from movie like atomic blonde
compared to the intensity of being a
student at the joffrey school for ballet
it's pretty similar that kind of
coordination that i was used to for so
many years through dance really helped
me with fight training because it really
is like like a dance yeah and the
injuries were quite so simple i imagine
that kind of wear and tear
is it's a lot i always like love being
in a corner with a fellow dancer and
just complaining about how many times we
had blood poisoning from blisters in our
feet that never got to heal and things
like that talk and shop with the
ballerinas you know just like that
[Music]
first we feast
little shout out to every bottle from
here on
i appreciate it especially for this one
so i understand that you initially had
trouble finding a buyer for monster you
know a film for which you won an academy
award almost went directly to video and
i'm wondering for someone who has a
spirit for independent filmmaking what
your read is on this disruption going on
in hollywood where you have these big
production houses failing you have
streaming sites making movies with some
of the biggest stars in the industry and
then even you know real actual
celebrities eating chicken wings on
youtube with a bald guy and i wonder
from your that's the best part of that
whole story what the hell is going on
here you know you need an evolution to
things and i think it's really up to us
in this industry or any industry to
really kind of pay attention to that
people like watching things at home and
this idea that really existed when i was
starting out in the business 20 years
ago when people like tom hanks said to
me you know
promise me you'll never do tv and like
now he's like one of the biggest tv
producers anybody will tell you who
works in this industry you really want
as many bums in the seat wherever that
seed is it really doesn't matter and
especially if
you know this alternative is showing us
that it's not in lack of quality why
would we not embrace that i'm in full
embrace of that very well said are you
ready to move on i think the hot sauce
is making me smart here we go
[Music]
there's a chicken on it that says
that's a shout out to that bottle
it says open for feel it repeat
i like that
all right charlie so every current
segment on our show called explain that
gram where you do a deep dive on our
guests instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context you're a
little too adult for a recurring segment
but we have a workaround we found some
great charlize theron gettys that we
just need to know more about so i'll
show you the picture and you just tell
me the bigger story does that sound good
all right laptop please i don't know if
there's gonna be a bigger story maybe
there's not but that's why you do the
segment you're hoping but this first one
actually is off the ig and i love it at
comic-con oh yeah and you have the whole
auditorium full of blondes yeah they're
all wearing the atomic blonde wigs
it's one of the first times i ever took
a selfie like that
just because i'd never seen an audience
be that
excited about a character or a film and
to go to that extent i mean they
literally had to walk from their hotels
with those blonde wigs big burly men
like were wearing the wigs and i was
just super impressed by that and touched
and i was like i've never done this
before but i think i want to take a
selfie with this crowd and they were
really some of them even were like
thigh-high boots like some of the men
were like thigh i just thought it was a
revolution yeah that's a real tip of the
cap to you too oh i don't think i well
thank you oh you know what i'm gonna
take that thank you it's all me
this is a great throwback
i'm playing golf with will smith did i
ever play golf is that ashley judd i
don't think that's me that is you can we
just talk about my perplexing very
focused stare
like i know what a putt is will was like
come do this this tournament and i was
like i don't really know how to play
like i'm really a terrible golfer and
but i wanted my mom to be a part of it
so much so i was trying really hard to
look like a golfer
but i am not a golfer will on the other
hand fancies himself a great golfer is
he though
[Music]
so there goes explain that gram you can
lose the laptop is that a chicken
with the fire coming out of its mouth
yeah thank you for noticing that's
that's impressive you're just being very
consistent we've really uh we really
screwed it down
extreme karma
is it this one
on the top or this one it's this one
yeah okay
don't want to [ __ ] it up
[Music]
it's good so i know that you're a mother
to two beautiful children and you seem
to have an affinity for the lifestyle
explaining to howard stern i'm asleep by
8 45 and i [ __ ] love it yeah what are
your kids favorite charlize theron
movies
that's a tough one because there's
really nothing for them to see
i did a movie years ago called mighty
joe young they watched like five minutes
and then they were just like out of the
room like they could i was just like
what like
why where's cgi can we put the ac on
please
it's a very pretty bottle with soft
writing somewhat romantic and i think
that's just to [ __ ] with me because it's
gonna be really not romantic puts you
into a false sense of security
okay
well there's a lot of flavor
i just got a lot of flavor mm-hmm
sausage
[Music]
all i got
i'm impressed with your tolerance
charlize really mm-hmm
why people will be just spicy for people
i've been on this side of the table for
a hundred guests at this point you know
i know you're so well if you'll allow me
to turn that spotlight back on you i
would say that you are in the clouds you
know like you're in a top percentile
space even in the room with no air
conditioning really
i don't know what the move is for that i
was gonna make a move but then i
panicked
i bailed last minute
it's gonna like slam my chest but then i
thought it was my boob and that's weird
we should move on
that was it all along is that it okay
all right
so i heard that you watch reality tv to
really
sorry let me try that over it's not easy
for me hot sauces you're making me feel
a lot better about myself
yes thank you
fumble some more just for my sake please
don't worry it's gonna happen
so i heard that you watch reality tv
because you really love watching human
behavior which sounds like a really good
excuse to get into some trashy corners
of deep cable yes what bizarre places
has that led you like did you ever see
that my strange addiction with that guy
who's dating his car yeah
the woman who married the
the the carnival ride
she married a carnival ride named bruce
and literally she worked on the carnival
ride 28 years before
and she fell in love with bruce and then
she was separated from bruce and the day
that she left bruce she got a necklace
and cut it in half and she pulled it she
poured it into one of the pipes of bruce
and then
her whole life was empty and she was
super sad and depressed and she found
bruce after 27 years or something and
she found the necklace and she married
bruce
what does that tell you about human
behavior that we are just [ __ ]
fantastic
this is like we are an endless ride of
anything can happen
and dab bomb
that's trying a little hard it looks
like a poison bottle with some kind of a
nuclear weapon on it right right
caution caution okay beyond insanity is
this one right
okay
[Music]
it comes in late
dublin comes in late and hard
super [ __ ] hard yeah
[Music]
that
i'm not going to hurt anybody's feelings
right no okay
that is the kind of spice that i'm not
crazy about because it doesn't have
flavor it's just like battery acid
[ __ ]
um
that's not
i don't there's no flavor
that's just
i'm on [ __ ] with you that's what that
sauce is
oh
it keeps growing too huh it's not
stopping no no
roller coaster
breathing hurts like when you breathe it
activates it yeah yeah
so know that you're a huge ufc fan i see
you by the cage and you're not afraid to
talk trash to some heavy weights every
once in a while i love it can you pull
back the curtain on what it's like to
watch a pay-per-view event with charlie
staring because i picture glasses flying
and tables being flipped
that's painful
yeah i mean i'm not no i'm not like
whenever i can reserve my energy i'm
usually
sitting on my couch
this is so hard
just being lazy
it takes a lot for me to be animated
[Music]
can i have some rice
i gotta try the rice
it's not like i like spice but that's
just like that's like somebody being an
[ __ ] right
it's like that's a dick move right there
yeah yeah
like i hate my tongue right now
if i could pull it out i would imagine
being me
and you know it's [ __ ] up because i
got part of it on one side of my lip but
not on the other side of my lip
real pro move ordering the rice by the
way this was a good backup don't you
think very smart very smart i don't know
if this does anything
okay
let's just i just want to flip that
bottle off like you just ruined this
whole thing for me mad dog better if i
can bring some flavor this sauce will
blow you away with number nine plutonium
just wait a little longer
stick let's take a breather
ask me one other question all right
let's go um some rice if you were in the
ufc what would your walkout song be
um that's a good one um
something by abba nice curveball
fernando okay okay just it would kind of
be like this [ __ ] sauce like you know
you like present something
soft and romantic and then you [ __ ] them
up
i don't know i'm like crazy right now
this sauce made me crazy
[Music]
because i think blisters are forming on
my tongue
i just love that you're encouraging me
through the hot sauce challenge it's you
know i've never had that before it's a
little bit interview it's a little bit
lunch it's a little bit life coach over
here i am grateful my friend okay that's
this one it looks like it has glitter on
it that's kind of abbish yeah it is how
spicy can it be it has glitter on it i i
think my mouth is dead so i'm gonna be
okay
well that has more flavor off the
is it a late kicker
just took my breath away
[Music]
but
kudos because that actually has a little
bit more flavor yeah
like i don't want to flip that one off
like that one
you respect it a little bit more from a
culinary perspective
there's
tones playing on my palette
that's not one-dimensional
exactly
the one side of my mouth is numb
so i know you're not shy about your
criticisms the media tabloid click bait
but i'm curious from your perspective
what's one thing that people who cover
the entertainment industry focus on too
much and what's one thing that they
don't focus on enough
oh wow that's a really good question
this is gonna sound so pretentious so
i'm just let it fly
i'm gonna blame it on the hot sauce
there's such an obsession about
celebrity versus actually just the work
and people are also i think interested
in more than just people talking about
whatever hollywood
boringness you can talk about for so
many years am i crying i feel like i'm
crying am i crying
you've got a glow i have a glow but i
wouldn't which means i'm really [ __ ]
sweaty
that's what that means
um
did we turn the ac on just out of
interest we did
we did
oh no what are you doing i thought it
was on there already
so it's funny that you say that this is
called the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
you don't have to if you don't want to
let me smell it
oh that is a [ __ ]
that is a [ __ ]
wow
garlicky
it says
i guess in fans alike into stuttering
fire breathing lunatics okay that's a
good copy chris it says but there's
pleasure in the pain so i'm gonna go
over it wow
oh come on
i don't want to like be crazy but i'll
go for that that's good that's good
textbook
let me be honest with you because you
were good about the other one sure sure
is this enough i'll always be real with
you all these people okay tell me i
don't want to lead the witness at all
but yeah we actually made this one okay
you made this sauce yeah
now you're really bragging
you asked i wasn't gonna bring it up i
was just gonna drive it and you made it
but here's what we did here's what i
think because there's a real culinary
challenge to making something that's hot
and tasty tasty anyone can make
something hot you can just take an
extract and just put that right through
but how do you do it with just natural
things that grow out of the ground you
know that's a real challenge it's a real
balancing act it's not it's not easy to
do yeah so
we made this one with that in mind is
that the challenge is that as the goal
so to me in my opinion not to lead the
witness this is the tastiest extreme hot
sauce ever made sold okay
that's tasty
am i dead am i still
you're still alive can i feel anything
wow my nose just
i like them
that i really like that's not
this [ __ ] sauce
can i just [ __ ] get rid of that one
that one destroyed the whole experience
for me that is actually really good i'm
taking this one too thank you we got you
a bag
we're two steps ahead of you
that's really good i like that yeah i
like it when it has flavor thank you
charlize i was really good the highest
of compliments i appreciate that good
job all right charlize there and here we
are at our journey's end you've spoken
in the past about how you have a
penchant for saying awkward or
uncomfortable things when you're under
extreme pressure yeah and i'm the exact
same way but that's not going to stop us
from praying on that vulnerability now
that you have 10 scorching hot chicken
wings and yes so what i have here is a
good old-fashioned wing 10 rorschach
test i'm just going to hit you with the
picture and you tell me the first thing
that comes to mind does that sound good
got it all right
penis
a mountain
my breakfast
a clown
an [ __ ]
can't argue with you there and look at
you charlize there and running the board
bringing out the rice getting on top of
the hot sauces so impressive from this
side of the table and i'm not just
saying that and now there's nothing left
to do but roll out the red carpet for
you charlize theron this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
well
let me start by saying no i have gringo
coming out march 9th and it is really
[ __ ] funny it's got great action
and the cast is okay but i'm in it so
and also
i i blue is not my favorite color
anymore i like yellow now
thanks guys
thank you thank you no i love it it's
real you guys are actually being
creative which is so much fun that one
is really good and this is like i mean
it's it's such a mild verb but it's
really flavorful we put this in here
thank you
but that is so garlicky and good
look in his bag show them we travel with
hot sauce everywhere we go beyonce
and we we we went to daytona and he had
these like little bottles because i love
i love hot sauce and they literally
stopped him and took it
hey what's going on hot ones fans it's
shawn evans and you know what i'm not
going to beg for your subscription if
you're not subscribed turn off the video
it's over i want just my subscribers
come here come here if you're subscribed
to first we feast i just want to say
thank you and then i appreciate you that
i love you and i hope that you have a
great day